good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the present
public i welcome you to this annual
meeting of the council
a bit of housekeeping as the expression
goes
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the building via the emergency
exits
i would advise that if filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
area may have their image captured i
urge anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
does anyone intend to film the
meeting i don't see any indications
any film you're recording will not be
permitted for any item of business where
exempt or confidential information is
considered following the exclusion of
the press and public from the meeting
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent and they are not used to make or
receive phone calls in the chamber while
the meeting is in progress
i try not to bring my phone along
actually
so agenda item number one the election
of chair i shall turn this over to the
vice chair
and i shall take the opportunity to
leave the chamber as i shall be a
candidate this evening
are there any nominations for the
election of chair
cancer ashby
thank you i
propose councillor jason savage
is there a second up
thank you
hi second that chair
councilor alban
yeah thank you chair i nominate
councillor ralph thank you well sorry
is there a second
thank you
yeah
as there are two nominations i'd like a
show of hands please
um those in favor of
uh councillor savage
please raise your hands
thank you very much those in favor of
council ralph
any abstentions
two
i hereby declare that councillor savage
has been elected to the office of chair
of thanat district council for the
ensuring year
congratulations council savage
[Applause]
please now be upstanding whilst the
platform party retires for a few minutes
in order for the chair to be invested
with the chain of badge and office
or he just comes in either way
please be seated
i presume i won you do
where am i right
[Music]
right
thank you very much indeed i call upon
the chief executive at this point
thank you i invite councillor savage as
the chair for 2022 23 to make the
declaration of acceptance of office
i councillor savage
having been elected to the office of
chairman of atlantic district council to
declare that i take the office upon
myself and would duly and faithfully
fulfill the duties
in accordance to the best of my judgment
and ability
and i shall sign
there's a tent listen
really what i'd like to say at this
point is having been outside the chamber
of course i had no idea who voted for me
and may not have voted for me and not
knowing i'm therefore in a position to
assume they all voted for me
which i'm rather delighted about
and i'm also very pleased to say i'll
take the office extremely seriously and
undertake the duties to the best of my
ability and thank you for the
opportunity of this fourth and what will
be i'm sure my final year as chairman of
this council
uh my escort for the year will of course
be my wife anne
who is not here this evening
she's a little shy
but nevertheless thank you very much
indeed members
moving on to agenda item two
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed
moving on to agenda item two the
election of the vice chair are there any
nominations
councillor ashby
sorry councillor david hart
thank you very much indeed do i have a
second
thank you very much councillor pugh
are there any other nominations
i don't see any other nominations
uh
and therefore i declare
councillor david hart vice chairman for
this year
council heart you can reassume your red
sash
scarlet sash would you like to say a few
words
oh sorry yes i call upon the chief
executive at this point
thank you
i invite councillor hart as the vice
chair for
2022-23 to make the declaration of
acceptance of offer
council heart would you like to say a
few words and advise who will be your
escort
yep thank you very much for the honor
again this is my second year or start
off
and
it's a very enjoyable position i must
admit and thank you very much and my
partner will be elizabeth hurst
thank you
thank you very much indeed councillor
hart
gender item three apologies for absence
i have received apologies from
councillor bailey councillor farence and
councillor scoby are there any other
apologies this evening
yes councillor curry
thank you chair
um yeah i have apologies from uh
councillor crittenden councillor
whitehead
councillor hopkinson
councillor ara
and councillor pat moore
was it something i said
i'm sure not counselor carrie
any other apologies i don't think so
no
agenda item before declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest this evening
and i don't see any
agenda item 5 minutes of previous
meetings agenda item 5a the minutes of
the 31st of march 2022 meeting a move
that the minutes of the meeting of
council held on the 31st of march 2022
be approved with the vice chair please
second
second that chair do members agree that
i signed the minute as a true record
thank you
i will do that later
agenda item 5 b the minutes of the 5th
of april 2022 meeting i move the minutes
of the meeting of council held on the
5th of april 2022 be approved with the
vice chair please second
second lecture
do members agree
thank you
gender item five is announcements and i
do not have any announcements in
accordance with the council procedure
rule 2.24
agenda item 7 responsibility for
functions and executive delegations i
call upon councillor ashby to name
cabinet members
thank you chair and i'm pleased to
announce that for the 22-23 municipal
year
councillor pugh
is to be the deputy leader and cabinet
member for economic development
councillor robert bayford cabinet member
for environmental services and special
projects councillor jill bayford cabinet
member for housing
councillor david saunders cabinet member
for finance and councillor george cupp
cabinet member for community safety and
youth engagement thank you chair
thank you very much councillor ashby i
call upon councillor everett to name
shadow cabinet members
yeah uh thank you chair and unlike
councillor ashby i i've written mine
down but i want to point out i've
written them down not because i don't
know who my shadow cabinet is but
because i have to remember these job
titles
so the shadow deputy leader and shadow
cabinet member for housing will be uh
councillor whitehead the shadow cabinet
member for finance council yates the
shadow cabinet member for environmental
services and special projects councillor
album the shadow cabinet member for
community safety and youth engagement
councilor keane and the shadow cabinet
member for economic development
councillor duckworth thank you
thank you very much indeed the i just to
say council is asked to receive the
cabinet portfolios cabinet portfolio
holders shadow cabinet portfolio holders
operational accountabilities and
executive delegated functions which we
have now just done
agenda item eight the constitution of
committees political balance
appointments committees panels and
boards with members please refer to
supplementary agenda number one
first of all the number and size of
committees i move the number of
committees and the number of
members to serve on those committees as
shown in table two of the report be
adopted subject to the proportionality
option agreed upon later in this agenda
with vice chair please second second
that chair do you members agree
thank you
moving on to political proportionality
i'm pleased to say that consensus among
group leaders has been achieved and so
therefore i move that council approves
the proportionality between groups four
committees panels and boards as shown in
adoption three of the report with the
vice chair please second
second that chair thank you do members
agree
thank you
moving on to nomination of members to
serve on committees
when members please note the nomination
subcommittees are shown in the members
notes
which i presume everyone has got i have
certainly had them
the election of chair and vice chair of
committees panels and boards for the
2022-2023 municipal year i call upon the
leader to move a list of nominations to
chair and vice chair positions
thank you chair
i'd like to propose planning committee
chair councillor tomlinson planning
committee vice chair councillor carmen
cook licensing board chair councillor
bambridge licensing board vice chair
councillor rogers
overview and scrutiny panel chair
councillor stuart piper overview and
scrutiny panel vice chair councillor
fellows
governance and audit chair councillor
boyd governance and audit vice chair
councillor dexter general purposes chair
myself councillor ashby joint transport
board vice chair maeve saunders
you very much indeed do members agree
i agree
thank you
my apologies council austin chair could
i just ask a question i noticed on some
of the printed documentation the term
chairman is still used can we ask that
that is is amended in
accordance with the agreement we made
about that
would you like to make a proposal to
that effect then
may i propose that that the term
chairman with regard to uh committees
etc of this council is changed to chair
hereafter thank you yes i understand
that and i'm sure we can take that on
board
councillor piper
just if i may a question please
uh chair
yes it was suggested that we use uh
non-sexual language but i think it was
also agreed i'm pretty sure
that it was up to the chair to decide
how they wish to be addressed either as
chair or chairman
or chairwoman or chairperson
i may be wrong about that so i'm happy
to be corrected by you if i am chair
there's a consensus of opinion up here
that that is the case but with assert
that it would be down to actual
individual chair people during that
meeting to decide on the the address
take made during that meeting
at this meeting i'm quite happy to be
called chairman
any meeting that is called that is held
it'll be up to that uh committee to
decide who
that what the form of address will be
and so whoever is holding a committee
meeting will be in a position to make
that decision
so if i think we can move on from that
point councillor austin you wish to come
back in i think just may i propose
therefore that all our documentation
uses the gender-neutral terminology and
then individual arrangements may be made
by
i'm reliably assured that that is
already taken into account council
austin right okay so we've got some
amends to make to the documentation that
went out for this meeting then yep okay
thank you
moving on to standard committees and
constitutional review working party
i move the council agrees the
appointment of michael clarke and caron
carolyn rushton
as independent members of the standards
committee until annual council in
2026.
in addition i further move that peter
tucker be appointed chair and peter
lorenzo be appointed vice chair of the
standard committee and the
constitutional review working party for
the
2022-2023 year
with the vice chair please second
second that chair
do members agree
agenda item 11 representation on outside
bodies i call upon the leader
counsel ashby
thank you chair
i propose that council agrees a list of
executive and non-executive outside
bodies and that council agrees the
nominations to the non-executive outside
bodies
cabinet will make the appointments to
the executive appointed outside bodies
at its next meeting on the 16th of june
2022. thank you chair
thank you very much is there a seconder
councillor pugh thank you do members
agree
thank you
gender item 12 calendar of meetings i
move that the recommendation is set out
in the report be adopted with the vice
chair please second
second that check do members agree
thank you
agenda item 30 members allowance scheme
for 2022-2023
i move that the east kent joint
independent remuneration panel's
recommendation as set out in the report
be agreed with the vice chair police
second
second lecture
do members agree
thank you
that concludes the business of this
annual meeting of the council